i
y
[Música]
[Aplausos]
cada 25 segundos muere una persona
alrededor del mundo víctima de un
siniestro vial
esos 25 segundos surgen de distribuir a
lo largo de un año y del tiempo que
tiene un año la cantidad de muertes que
ocurren anualmente esas muertes
estimadas por la organización mundial de
la salud equivalen a un millón 250 mil
personas el número parece enorme y es un
poquito pequeño si pensamos en la
cantidad de personas que sufren algún
tipo de lesión y que viven luego con
algún tipo de lesión producto o algún
siniestro vial
es el número de personas está estimado
entre 20 y 50 millones si volvemos a la
distribución diaria de las lesiones de
las muertes
encontramos que 786 personas 786
motociclistas mueren en algún siniestro
vial 752 peatones 137 ciclistas eso
diariamente el vector de energía que
causa las lesiones que posteriormente
terminan en algún tipo de deceso siempre
es un automóvil en la argentina se
estima y posiblemente de manera
conservadora que mueren alrededor de a
lo largo de un año cinco mil 613
personas si lo convertimos en días se
trata de 15 muertes diariamente en
nuestro país
los números son números que posiblemente
apabullan que posiblemente nos podrían
hacer sentir mal contrariamente a eso
hemos intentado intentamos encontrar las
explicaciones posibles para entender por
qué ocurre y para además de entender por
qué ocurre tratar de que ocurran en
menor cantidad y en alguna medida el
objetivo más amplio o más ambicioso
sería que no ocurrieran encontramos y
buscamos muchas formas de explicarlo
hemos pensado en la infraestructura
hemos pensado en los automóviles también
hemos pensado en el comportamiento
humano que al que llamamos generalmente
factor humano algo que tal vez no le
hemos prestado tanta atención han sido a
factores sociales dentro de esos
factores sociales hay uno que es el que
me interesa compartir con ustedes que es
la cultura todos sabemos y
cotidianamente pensamos o no sé si
cotidianamente pero habitualmente
pensamos que tenemos algún tipo de
cultura o que compartimos aspectos
culturales que nos hacen parecernos unos
a otros en ese sentido la cultura se
podría definir como
la programación colectiva de las mentes
en términos simbólicos en términos
prácticos que se puede ver expresado en
instituciones sociales se puede ver
expresado también en comportamientos en
significados compartidos o en artefactos
la cultura obviamente es muy amplia es
muy difícil que la podamos abarcar en el
rato que tenemos para compartir pero
dentro de toda esa amplitud a mí me
interesa compartir y comentarles a
ustedes una dimensión que es denominada
masculinidad feminidad esta dimensión se
refiere a en qué medida dentro de
distintas culturas dentro de sí
a veces posiblemente dentro de los
límites geográficos de un país se
valoran más o menos rasgos o
características que tradicionalmente son
masculinas o tradicionalmente son
femeninas es importante por ahí retener
esta palabra tradicional o
tradicionalmente
rasgos tradicionalmente masculinos
en enfocados son marcados dentro de esta
dimensión que estamos compartiendo son
la dureza la resistencia la
autoafirmación o la autosuficiencia
posiblemente la agresividad también hay
otros rasgos que es que se genere se
consideran típicamente masculinos como
la valoración positiva del riesgo cierta
preocupación leve o menor por el cuidado
de la salud y que muchas veces se
transfiere a sociedades donde sobresalir
de manera individual es más importante
quizás que el bienestar colectivo
o tal vez aparecen diferencias de género
que son más marcadas diferencias entre
varones y mujeres y en donde las que en
las cuales la presión para los varones
para adecuarnos a ese rol de género
tradicional es un poco más fuerte
por el contrario del otro lado de las
sociedades que los valores que son
típicamente considerados femeninos o
esos rasgos se encuentran la amabilidad
la compasión el compromiso la empatía
también una valoración menor positiva
del riesgo y una valoración un cuidado
mayor o una valoración mayor hacia el
cuidado de la salud
obviamente hay características sociales
que difieren de las sociedades más
masculinas se tratan de sociedades donde
el cuidado o el compromiso por el bien
común es mayor y entonces el bienestar
colectivo está por encima de destacarse
individualmente también hay una
valoración mayor de llegar a acuerdos
a diálogos para resolver conflictos y
las diferencias de género son menos
marcadas y también es menos marcada la
presión hacia los varones para adecuarse
a esa diferencia
a esas diferencias o ese rol de género
tradicional es importante señalar que
cuando hablamos de masculinidad femenina
en términos culturales no nos estamos
refiriendo al rol de género no se trata
de como cada uno de las personas cada
individuo se considera a sí mismo varón
o mujer o como cada persona ha ido
construyendo su identidad de género que
es algo que va a estar influido
seguramente por esos valores sociales
culturales compartidos pero también en
cada persona responde a su pauta
personal de socialización en el seno
familiar en sus grupos de pertenencia y
que después va a estar cotidianamente
afirmado o no a través de los mensajes
sociales referidos a las diferencias de
género obviamente sabemos hoy en día que
el rol de género no está relacionado
directamente con nuestras
características sexuales biológicas con
ser varón o mujer en términos biológicos
la cultura entonces decíamos es muy
amplia muy amplia y es difícil de acotar
y difícil de acotar en poco tiempo pero
hay un elemento o un intermedio entre la
cultura de esta cultura tan amplia que
compartimos y lo que ocurre a nivel vial
o a nivel del tránsito lo que ocurre
cuando estamos en la calle yendo y
viniendo y por eso hemos encontrado o
hemos buscado tratar de definirlo con un
concepto que es el de cultura vial
cuando hablamos de cultura vial nos
referimos a las valoraciones las
percepciones las actitudes y los
comportamientos que tenemos como
colectivo y también individualmente
hacia la seguridad vial pero también
hacia la movilidad y hacia el transporte
yo creo que no me equivoco sí supongo
que la mayoría de ustedes cuando piensan
en tránsito se figuran algún tipo de
automóvil circulando o yendo y viniendo
y posiblemente un poco de caos o de
incomodidad
esto es así porque
en gran medida nuestra cultura vial es
una cultura donde lo que predominan son
los automóviles hasta el punto que
algunos hablan de la cultura del
automóvil directamente más que de la
cultura vial esta cultura del automóvil
o la cultura vial tiene varios problemas
uno de los problemas que tiene es que es
poco equitativa
y poco diversa podríamos decir también
porque el fuego y equitativa' porque los
automóviles se estima se calcula en
ciudades del tamaño de mar del plata o
en ciudades quizás más grandes ocupan el
70% del espacio público uno podría
pensar bueno pero tienen alguna
finalidad cumplen con una función y nos
ayudan a ir y venir a obtener recursos a
comunicarnos con nuestros amigos
etcétera etcétera sin embargo los
automóviles son el medio de transporte
del 40 por ciento de los viajeros que
diariamente van de un lugar al otro eso
quiere decir que ocupan casi tres
cuartas partes del espacio pero son
fuentes de movilidad para menos de la
mitad de las personas el resto del
espacio debería ser utilizado por
motociclistas por ciclistas por peatones
como vemos ahí hay algo de falta de
equidad falta de un uso compartido del
espacio
hay otros elementos más este este
elemento o esta falta de equidad puede
ser visible para todos todos sabemos que
hay muchos autos en la calle por algunas
cosas que quedan un poco más ocultas
detrás de eso y que no son tan comunes
para la mayoría de nosotros una de ellas
es que los autos además de transportar a
muy poca gente suelen ser el medio de
movilidad más habitual en varones
varones adultos varones posiblemente de
clase media o superior y no de otros
grupos sociales muchos de ustedes en
este mismo momento estarán pensando que
eso no puede ser así que posiblemente
son mujeres y manejan o conocen a
alguien que es mujer y maneja y otro
montón de situaciones más entonces para
que quede un poco más claro vamos a ir
compartiendo un poco de información que
le da sustento a esto que yo acabo de
afirmar para eso vamos a empezar con un
poco de historia siempre la historia es
interesante porque nos muestra los
orígenes de algo y también posiblemente
puede marcar su devenir para la mayoría
de nosotros nombres como henry ford
o carl benz o ferdinand porsche son
nombres familiares no suenan si no
sabemos exactamente de donde rápidamente
entendemos que se trata de personas que
estuvieron relacionadas con el origen
del automóvil y es así son los que
muchas veces se conocen como padres del
automóvil
sin embargo hay otros nombres que no son
tan tan comunes que no escuchamos a
menudo yo traje tres para compartir uno
es el de berta events marie anderson
dorothy levitt son mujeres que
estuvieron involucradas en el origen del
automóvil como objeto pero que no son
tan reconocidas
berta events fue la mujer de carl benz y
además de eso fue la primera mujer en
realizar un viaje en auto que unió dos
ciudades
berta una noche que quería visitar a su
mamá y se llevó el auto no le avisó a
carl obviamente se llevó el auto y se
fue con los hijos a visitar a la madre
ese fue el primer viaje en auto y además
se considera que fue como la primera
operación de marketing a favor del auto
porque a partir de ahí el auto fue
considerado un vehículo que podría tener
realmente a una utilidad a nivel social
marie anderson inventó el
limpiaparabrisas dorothy levitt fue
piloto de carreras fue estructura de
manejo de la realeza británica escribió
un libro que se llamó the woman and the
car que fue publicado en 1903 y además
se inventó el espejo retrovisor el
espejo retrovisor y el limpiaparabrisas
no fueron incluidos en la fabricación de
automóviles hasta que la patente que
ellas generaron y que tenía cierta
vigencia caducó recién después de eso
ford empezó a incluir estos objetos en
la fabricación de automóviles son
objetos que nos acompañan hoy hoy día
y que hacen el viaje algo mucho más
seguro de lo que era en aquel entonces
obviamente podríamos dar más nombres los
orígenes míticos son muchas veces
orígenes míticos pero suelen como decía
hace un ratito marcar el devenir de las
cosas entonces vengamos al presente y
veamos qué pasa con la industria del
transporte en la industria del
transporte en américa latina' las
mujeres ocupan sólo el 15 por ciento de
la fuerza de trabajo esto es a nivel ya
sea gerencial o a nivel de operarios a
nivel gerencial se entiende fácilmente
con lo que conocemos como techo de
cristal pero a nivel de operarios
alguien podría suponer que que tal vez
las mujeres tienen menos capacidades
para hacer esa tarea pero no es así no
hay ningún tipo de evidencia científica
que avale que existen diferencias que
justifiquen que haya menos mujeres en la
industria del transporte
esto es importante no sólo por el acceso
al trabajo sino porque la presencia de
mujeres en la industria del transporte
también permitiría que la percepción y
las necesidades de la mujeres fuera más
visible
relacionado con lo que decíamos hace un
rato al principio
promediando al principio de la charla
sobre el uso de los autos por los
varones en la argentina 1 de cada 3
licencias de conducir está en manos de
mujeres
eso quiere decir que hay menos mujeres
manejando si pensamos no solo en la
estadística sino en términos de lo que
ocurre cotidianamente sería posible más
posiblemente más porque las mujeres
cuando hay un auto compartido en la
familia manejan menos que los hombres
podríamos hacer el ejercicio de ir a una
esquina pararnos y contar autos pasar y
ver quién maneja si una mujer un varón y
después si hay dos personas en el auto
ver si la que maneja es un varón o una
mujer yo estoy seguro que el resultado
siempre va a ser abrumadoramente mayor
en el caso de los varones
otro elemento más para compartir y es
que los automóviles y la publicidad de
los automóviles generalmente nos habla y
les habla a los varones nos dice que si
compramos un auto vamos a ser más
inteligentes más fuertes posiblemente
más atractivos y que las mujeres van a
gustar más de nosotros contrariamente a
eso suele suceder que cuando las
publicidades intentan incentivar el uso
de la bicicleta a otros medios de
transporte se dirigen hacia mujeres
hacia niños o algún varón que aparece un
poco ridiculizado y nunca es tan
atractivo como cuando tiene un auto
salgamos de los datos que son ahora
históricos culturales sociológicos y
vayamos a datos que relacionan aspectos
científicos podríamos decir estudios
sobre comportamiento vial y estas
dimensiones culturales de masculinidad
feminidad en primer lugar importa decir
que el comportamiento riesgoso en el
tránsito es más habitual entre los
varones los varones jóvenes son
mayormente los que exhiben algo que se
conoce como estilo riesgoso de la
conducción que está directamente
asociado a la probabilidad de sufrir o
perdón de de participar en siniestros
más graves y sufrir alguna muerte o
alguna lesión grave una muerte una
lesión grave es más el grupo de personas
entre 15 y 29 años que son varones y
dentro de esa edad son los que más
expuestos están a morir en un siniestro
vial y es la principal causa de muerte
para ese grupo de edad
es importante también señalar que el
estilo riesgoso suele disminuir cuando
disminuye el índice de masculinidad a
nivel social y también hay algo
relacionado con la velocidad y los
límites de velocidad en términos
culturales las sociedades con índices de
masculinidad más baja tienen límites de
velocidad más bajos los límites de
velocidad más bajos tienden a proteger
al usuario más vulnerable
en un atropello figuremos una situación
de atropellos atropellan a 10 personas a
30 kilómetros por hora obviamente no
todos juntas sino una una bueno una de
esas 10 muere y otras 9 sobreviven a 50
kilómetros por hora el número es al
revés es inverso por el 9 sobrevivir una
sola eso es muy importante en términos
de protección de usuarios vulnerables
por otra parte las sociedades más
masculinas además de que los límites son
más altos los límites de velocidad son
más altos también suele suceder que la
transgresión de esos límites es mayor
otro aspecto que es más habitual en
sociedades con índices de masculinidad
más alta y es más habitual entre los
varones es el comportamiento agresivo en
el tránsito la agresividad puede ser
producto de algún tipo de reacción
emocional nos frustramos sentimos ira y
expresamos esa agresividad ya sea con el
automóvil ya sea gritando insultando
pero también puede ser que la
agresividad sea un instrumento que
consideremos que utilizando el auto de
una manera agresiva obtengamos alguna
ventaja como por ejemplo pasar más
rápido que otro bueno eso es más
habitual en sociedades más masculinas
al revés o por el lado contrario
sociedades con índices de masculinidad
más bajos menores tienden a proteger al
usuario vulnerable tienden a tener
infraestructura que protege al ciclista
que protege al peatón y hace mucho
énfasis en el uso del transporte público
el énfasis en el uso del transporte
público es importante porque los
principales usuarios de ese transporte
son las mujeres los niños y los ancianos
y eso no es algo que sea solo en
argentina es en el mundo entero
obviamente que sean las mujeres está
relacionado con que conducen menos
obviamente que sean las mujeres y que
hayan menos mujeres en la industria del
transporte hace que las necesidades de
las mujeres sean menos visibles y que
por ejemplo no se contemplen cosas como
las tareas de cuidado a la hora de
generar patrones de frecuencia y de
viaje en los transportes de colectivos
proteger al usuario más vulnerable
proteger a los ancianos a los niños hace
obviamente del espacio público algo más
amigable hace un ratito decíamos que
cuando pensamos en tránsito la mayoría
de nosotros se figura automóviles figura
autos yendo y viniendo a velocidad ruido
y decíamos también que eso es un
problema en términos de equidad
el tránsito y la palabra tránsito
lo que hace es vehiculizar sentidos
además de vehiculizar personas o sea
pensamos y se nos ocurren significados y
cosas cuando pensamos en el tránsito la
cultura está relacionada con esos
significados tránsito es ir y venir es
pasar de un lado a otro pero no es
permanecer no es quedarse no es vivir en
ese lugar entonces cuando pensamos en
tránsito la ciudad deja de ser un lugar
donde vivimos y donde pasamos tiempo
colectivamente y pasa a ser un lugar de
pasaje posiblemente un lugar cada vez
más peligroso hay muchas iniciativas y
muchos planteos que sostienen que hay
que volver a la escala humana en el
tránsito que necesitamos calles
completas que la ciudad debe ser la
ciudad de los niños o que el diseño de
las ciudades debe ser universal también
me parece a mí que una manera
interesante de pensar las ciudades es
pensarlas como ecosistemas un ecosistema
aprendimos en la escuela está plagado de
organismos de seres vivos que están
viviendo y buscando un equilibrio con su
ambiente y entre sí si pensamos de esa
manera entonces de repente la ciudad no
es el tránsito la ciudad es un
ecosistema donde vivimos cotidianamente
donde además de autos hay peatones y
bicicletas hay motos pero además de
haber peatones bicicletas motos medios
de transporte hay personas hay niños hay
mujeres hay adultos adultos mayores hay
personas con discapacidad en la medida
que pensemos la ciudad de esa manera la
ciudad se vuelve diversa se vuelve más
equitativa se vuelve más amigable e
indudablemente la ciudad se vuelve mucho
más segura para todos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]